well I don't know what your definition
of patriotism is and mine is so
complicated that it would take up some
time I do think that it is a form of
patriotic expression we have now come to
use patriotism in the most superficial
and politically isolating way we use it
to tar people whose opinions we don't
agree with or use it as a weapon to tell
people why their opinions render them
unpatriotic that's not what I'm
interested in I think that for some
reason or another this combination of an
interest in film and an interest in
American history has also formed in me a
kind of deep and abiding love not
without criticism every one of my films
because it deals with rated race is
implicitly critical at the United States
and the path that it quite often takes
but at the same time it understands
something larger I'm interested in
listening to the voices of a true honest
complicated past that is unafraid of
controversy and tragedy but equally
drawn to those stories and moments that
suggests an abiding faith in the human
spirit and particularly the unique role
this remarkable but also sometimes
dysfunctional republic seems to play in
the positive progress of mankind that's
my create and I think that is a higher
form of patriotism
the quirky appeal they might or might
not appeal to others or so-called buffs
as your question says doesn't interest
me at all I'm interested in that
complicated pass i'm interested in
telling stories the fact that my
interests might intersect with others
who are drawn to the Civil War is I
guess good but I that's not what I need
to focus on all I'm trying to do is tell
a good story and telling a good story is
incredibly difficult and hard
undertaking that requires the talents of
a lot of amazing people that I have the
good fortune to work with to do that I'm
not sure that your question is entirely
correct buffs don't sort of attend to
these films it is true that there are
Civil War buffs and they find in my film
and other books and other films that
have been made a kind of re-energizing
of their interests but the films
themselves exist quite above whatever
superficial sentimental and nostalgic
relationship that so often buffs have
I'm disinterested in sentimentality and
nostalgia in fact it's not only the
enemy of good storytelling it's the
enemy of good history I'd rather though
not retire to a kind of rational world
in which one and one equals two all the
time that's the safety of the empirical
world the rational world all of us want
deep down in some unexpressed way for 1
in 12 equal 3 and it's that calculus
that an artist pursues its that calculus
that drives you that improbable
mathematical possibility that one and
one could equal 3 is part of what we do
we say all the time that we wish the
whole to be greater than the sum of the
parts but we don't really examine the
difference between the sum of the parts
and the whole and that difference is
what makes art art which makes
literature work what makes us love which
compels the most important aspects of
our lives and that has nothing to do
with butts
I was interviewing for film biography of
Mark Twain more than 10 years ago the
novelist's Russell banks and we were
talking about Huckleberry Finn which I
believe and he believed was Mark Twain's
most important novel and he said you
know it's our Iliad and our Odyssey
which really struck me and he said
though most of us share the same
European tradition that produced the
illy in the Odyssey we Americans were
grappling with two new themes that our
European ancestors weren't it so we
required a new Iliad a new odyssey to
help us grapple with these in Twain
alone among writers and philosophers and
politicians of the 19th century knew and
understood and was willing to deal with
and entwine these two themes one was
race and the other was space not outer
space but the physical geography of the
United States I don't go looking for
race in my films it's just there you
can't scratch the surface of the most
important event in American history the
civil war without coming up of course
against the question of race you can't
deal with the story of baseball another
great subject without understanding that
its finest moment is when jack roosevelt
robinson the grandson of a slave made
his way to first base that have its
field on april fifteenth nineteen forty
seven it's about race that so much of
the biographies that we've done on
Thomas Jefferson on Mark Twain on
Elizabeth Cady Stanton and susan b
anthony I'm Lewis and Clark on Jack
Johnson inevitably I don't know a film
with the possible exception of Frank
Lloyd Wright that didn't engage race in
some way or another not because we went
looking for it but because we had
committed as we were to dealing with not
a superficial portrayal of a certain
event in American history it had found
us and so race is always there the space
is a different thing the physicality of
the United States works on us in ways
were were so unaware first of all we
have this magnificent continent
particularly the western part of the
United States which has been a draw to
people from all over but we're also
because we are a democratic society our
society trying to be democratic
experience the freedom of movement at
all class levels traditionally movement
was of armies or of the very rich
in Europe and in other situations that a
family in a feudal situation could stay
for hundreds and hundreds of years in
the same spot but in America even the
lowliest worker could travel and did and
the national parks become part of the
verifying of that co-ownership of the
idea of America as well as the
physicalness of America so we're always
bumping into a question of race we're
always bumping into this question of the
physicality the space of the United
States and it was nice to have someone
as brilliant as Russell banks a great
great novelist in his own right deliver
it to us in such an easy understandable
thing but he was essentially describing
what has engaged my energies for 35 +
years